ALAN ARCHULETA ADKINS EIGHTIES
BACKER FORGES BRADFORD BY AERO
CORTEZ C. DALLEY DOT THE RUSSELL
AIKMAN GLAZER CONSOLIDATES GROVE
HURTS BERG WEST SO HER TADO
JONES CAMCORDER LAYERED LABOR
THE MON WIRE MELINDA'S MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A TROUBLED PAN
FORTUNE TINO RALPH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN ON BOURKE WHITE HOUSE SKI. WINNER WELL. MEMBERS IF YOU
COULD TAKE YOUR SEATS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WITH THE MEMORY OF
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE REAL IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR DRAWS SO
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL DELIVER THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR CORTESE SENATOR ALSO
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THESE
ARE WORDS TAKEN FROM A PRAYER OF
CORETTA SCOTT KING. ETERNAL AND
EVERLASTING GOD CREATOR OF ALL
HUMANKIND. AS WE TURN ASIDE FROM
THE HURLY BURLY OF EVERYDAY
LIVING. THEY ARE HEARTS AND
SOULS C. A. R. VERY SPIRITS. HE
LIFTED UP WORDS TO YOU. FOR IT
IS FROM YOU THAT ALL BLESSINGS
COME. KEEP US EVER MINDFUL OF
OUR DEPENDENCE UPON YOU FOR
WITHOUT YOU OUR EFFORTS ARE BUT
NOT. WE PRAY FOR YOUR DIVINE
GUIDANCE AS WE TRAVEL THE
HIGHWAYS OF LIFE WE PRAY FOR
MORE COURAGE WE PRAY FOR MORE
FAITH. AND ABOVE ALL WE PRAY FOR
MORE LOVE. MAY WE SOMEHOW COME
TO UNDERSTAND THE TRUE MEANING
OF YOUR LOVE. AND WE TRY TO LIVE
IT DAY BY DAY EMAN. PLEASE JOIN
ME I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO. YEAH. VERY GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED RED AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. MOTION TO APPROVE THE
SENATE JOURNALS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR THE WEEK OF FEBRUARY
FIFTEENTH THROUGH THE EIGHTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WILL IT BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH SENATE THIRD READING
FILE ITEM FIVE. SENATOR DODD
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY SIX RELATIVE TO EATING
DISORDERS AWARENESS WEEK.
SENATOR DODD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS S.
C. R. SIXTY SIX RECOGNIZES THE
WEEK OF FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE FEBRUARY
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AS EATING DISORDERS AWARENESS
WEEK IN THE UNITED STATES THIRTY
MILLION INDIVIDUALS SUFFER FROM
CLINICALLY SIGNIFICANT EATING
DISORDERS AT SOME TIME IN THEIR
LIFE. THESE DISORDERS AFFECT MEN
AND WOMEN ACROSS ALL BACKGROUNDS
INCLUDE ANOREXIA NERVOSA-
BULIMIA NERVOSA AND BINGE EATING
DISORDER. COLLEAGUES I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND HOW PAINFUL AND
DIFFICULT THESE DISORDERS CAN BE
I'VE HAD A LOVED ONE WHO
SUFFERED FROM AN EATING DISORDER
. I'VE ALSO SEEN THAT RECOVERY
IS POSSIBLE. AND I CAN ATTEST TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF AWARENESS
UNDERSTANDING AND A STRONG
SUPPORT NETWORK FOR THOSE THERE
ON THAT JOURNEY TO RECOVERY.
NATIONAL EATING DISORDERS
AWARENESS WEEK IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BY EATING
DISORDER PROFESSIONALS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS STUDENTS.
EDUCATORS SOCIAL WORKERS AND
INDIVIDUALS TO RAISE AWARENESS
EATING DISORDERS AND A CRITICAL
NEED FOR EARLY INTERVENTION. AND
TREATMENT ACCESS THIS RESOLUTION
SERVES TO FURTHER THE
CONVERSATION AROUND EATING
DISORDERS THE SHINE A LIGHT ON
THESE DEADLY ILLNESSES. DISPEL
MISINFORMATION AND CONNECT
PEOPLE WITH THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED TO RECOVER. RECOVER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE OF THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA. I HAD KENS
FIVE BASE I BACKER FIVE FORGES I
BRADFORD. BY ADAM ARE YOU
PROTECTING I. DALI I DON. HI
TORONTO I EGGMAN I. LASER EYE
CONSOLIDATES I GROW. I HEARD
SPURRED I WAS SO. I- TANTO.
JONES HI CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LIVE. I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH I CAN.
I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI RUBIO
. I SKINNER I STERN I REMEMBER I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. I WILL HI
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED BY MEMBERS WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEM SEVEN ALSO
SENATOR DODD MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT AND DECLARED
THERE TO SEE THEIR UPSTATE FOR
TO ME LIFE CENTERED ON. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
EIGHTY FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
REQUIRES CAL ONLY US TO
ESTABLISH DON'T DONATION SYSTEM
FOR PRIVATE BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
INTERESTED IN ASSISTING WITH
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS. THROUGH
THIS SYSTEM PRIVATE NONPROFIT
ENTITIES WILL BE ABLE TO DONATE
SERVICES GOODS LABOR EQUIPMENT
RESOURCES OR FACILITIES FOR USE
DURING EMERGENCIES. EXISTING LAW
AUTHORIZES THE USE OF STATEWIDE
DONATIONS REGISTRY BUT IS NOT
REQUIRE IMPLEMENTATION
CONSIDERING THE ONGOING PANDEMIC
AND THE THREAT OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES EARTHQUAKES AND
FLOODS. THERE'S AN URGENCY FOR
CAL- WE US TO ESTABLISH THIS
SYSTEM TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY AS WELL AS A SYSTEM
RESPONSE RECOVERY FOR FUTURE
DISASTERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
MEMBERS IN THE DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ALL EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. OUR MEMBERS
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR
EGGMAN. THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
THREE WILL MEET IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. AT TEN THIRTY. HOW BOUT
TWENTY FORTY AT THREE O'CLOCK
OKAY PERFECT. THREE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY AT THREE O'CLOCK THANK YOU
SENATOR EDMUND. MEMBERS WE'RE
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR A JOURNEY
MEMORIES WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH SENATOR GONZALEZ SENATOR
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF TERRY
ROGERS A CHERISHED FRIEND
CONSTITUENT IN MY DISTRICT AND
RESIDENT OF SIGNAL HILL. TERRY
ROGERS PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TERRY LOVED HER CITY AND
COMMUNITY SHE SERVED AS A SIGNAL
HILL PARKS AND RECREATION
COMMISSIONER AND ON THE BOARDS
OF THE SIGNAL HILL POLICE
FOUNDATION SIGNAL HILL COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION SIGNAL HILL CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE SIGNAL HILL
HISTORICAL SOCIETY AND FRIENDS
OF THE SIGNAL HILL LIBRARY. NOT
TO MENTION SHE LOVED SIGNAL HILL
HER SERVICE ALSO EXTENDED TO THE
SIGNAL HILL ROTARY SALVATION
ARMY AND ROCK FOR VETS MUSIC IS
THE REMEDY SHE WORKED IN THE
REAL ESTATE INDUSTRY FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND HAD LIVED
IN SIGNAL HILL SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN. I SAW HER LAST
DURING THE CHRISTMAS BREAK AND
SHE WAS SO WARM AND KIND AS
ALWAYS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY AND
OUR- CONDOLENCES TO HER FAMILY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ PLEASE BE SURE TO BRING
HER NAME FOR IT SO SHE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. MEMBERS
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK EVERYONE TO
TAKE THEIR SEATS SO THAT WE CAN
DO OUR ADJOURNING MEMORIES AND
BE RESPECTFUL TO THOSE THAT WE
ARE HONORING PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE. FLOOR SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
pOF JOAN DIDION. A NOVELIST AND
WRITER BORN RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. THE SALLY PASSED
AWAY ON DECEMBER TWENTY THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY SEVEN. CITY SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA LOST A REVERED AUTHOR
AND ESSAYIST WHOSE PRECISE
SOCIAL AND PERSONAL COMMENTARY
MADE HER A UNIQUELY CLEAR EYED
CRITIC OF TURBULENT TIMES. BORN
IN SACRAMENTO AND A GRADUATE OF
MCCLATCHY HIGH SCHOOL- SHE
ACTUALLY WROTE WELL SHE'S IN
HIGH SCHOOL FOR THE SECOND A
UNION WRITING FOR THE SOCIETY
DESK WHICH HELPED INFORM SOME
FOR LATER WRITING. BEFORE SHE
WENT TO UC BERKELEY. IN HER
FAMOUS ESSAY COLLECTION AND-
SLOUCHING TOWARD BETHLEHEM AS
JOAN DIDION WROTE I PERMISSION
TO READ. WITHOUT OBJECTION. THAT
IS WHAT I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO COME FROM A
PLACE LIKE SACRAMENTO. IF I
COULD MAKE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT I
CAN MAKE YOU UNDERSTAND
CALIFORNIA. HAVE SOMETHING ELSE
BESIDES FOR SACRAMENTO IS
CALIFORNIA. OF COURSE WASWIDELY
RECOGNIZED FOR HER LITERARY
WORK- JOAN DIDION RECEIVED THE
GOLD MEDAL FOR BELLS LETTERS
FROM THE AMERICAN ARTS ACADEMY
OF ARTS AND LETTERS IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE IS THE HIGHEST
HONOR FOR THE ACADEMY FOR WRITER
SHE IS ALSO AWARDED THE NATIONAL
HUMANITIES MEDAL IN TWENTY
TWELVE TO BRING FORTH IMPORTANT
TOPICS. THE DISSECTION OF
POLITICS AND CULTURE IN THE
TWENTY THIRTEEN PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA PRESENTED HER WITH THE
NATIONAL MEDAL OF ARTS IN HIS
SPEECH PRESIDENT OBAMA DISCUSSED
HER LUCID STYLE AN INCISIVE
DESCRIPTIONS OF SOCIAL UNREST
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL FRAGMENTATION
. TODAY REMEMBER JOAN DIDION FOR
BEING A TOWERING ICON OF
LITERARY JOURNALISM AND-
DEPICTIONS OF CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE. WE SEND
OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO HER
FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND AFTER WE
JOINED IN HER MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR PM PLEASE BRING
HER NAME FORWARD SO SHE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. SENATOR
WIENER. MMHM. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES- I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF BOB PLAN
HOLD- BOB WHO WAS BORN IN SAINT
LOUIS AND MOVED TO SAN FRANCISCO
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE- HE
CONTRACTED POLIO WHEN HE WAS
ONLY FOURTEEN MONTHS OLD- AND
AFTER NUMEROUS SURGERIES HE'D BE
REQUIRED TO USE CRUTCHES AND
CANES TO WALK FOR THE REST OF
HIS LIFE- BOB WAS. A VERY WELL
KNOWN. AND VERY RESPECTED SAN
FRANCISCO TRANSIT ACTIVIST. WHO
BROUGHT ATTENTION THE BARRIERS-
FACING PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND ACCESSING TRANSIT- AND HE
GAVE VOICE TO SO MANY PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. OUR BOB HAS
RECEIVED MANY RECOGNITIONS OVER
THE COURSE OF HIS- ADVOCACY
INCLUDING FROM CALTRANS CALTRAIN
AND FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
PARATRANSIT COUNCIL- ABOUT THAT
HE KILLED MANY YEARS OF HIS LIFE
PROVIDING VALUABLE EMPLOYMENT
ADVOCACY FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
MAYOR'S DISABILITY COUNCIL. HE
KNEW THE LOBBYING WOULD NOT
ALWAYS BE EASY BUT HE
NEVERTHELESS ENCOURAGE OTHERS TO
KEEP THE LIGHTS AND- HUMOR- IN
THEIR CAMPAIGNS- BOB WOULD
ALWAYS- FORWARD FUNNY EMAILS
SOMETIMES WITH THE SUBJECT LINE.
HERE'S SOMETHING TO BRIGHTEN
YOUR DAY HE WOULD REGULARLY SEND
ME EMAILS THAT WERE JUST VERY
SWEET AND ENCOURAGING- WHICH IS
ALWAYS THE NICE THING IS ELECTED
OFFICIAL TO RECEIVE EVEN A- JOB
I CAN BE EXTREMELY INTENSE AND
NEGATIVE AT TIMES. ABOUT SERVICE
TO THE COMMUNITY AT HIS
DEDICATION TO SAN FRANCISCO AND
THE PEOPLE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES- WILL BE REMEMBERED
BY EVERYONE THAT HE TOUCHED HE
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH AT HOME AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY THREE. HE WAS A LOVING
FATHER AND A VALUED MEMBER OF
OUR SAN FRANCISCO COMMUNITY OUR
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
DURING THE SENATE AND MEMORY. OF
PARKLAND HOLD. THANK YOU SO
WIENER PLEASE HIS SAFE SO HE MAY
BE. MEMORIALIZED BY THE CAL
STATE SENATE. MEMBERS IF THERE
IS NO FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER AT
KANSAS THE DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS ONLY
TWO DAYS AWAY THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AT NINE AM THANK YOU. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM. HAVE A GREAT REST TODAY
MEMBERS.